oh fudge
the sixth pop star to die in the last
year all with that look peace out world
there is only one person who would know
how to interpret this look I'm out of
fashion I lost fire you're Derek
Zoolander is dr. Chinese throwing star
with a look flash me that beautiful
Magnum wait no Magnum now
oh maybe we could try a washcloth Derek
Zoolander I'm with Interpol global
fashion division she's hot I trust her
what do you know about fashion I was a
swimsuit models person sorry i was never
able to transition to your world because
of this gross are you sure someone at
door is the right man well bus hey
handsome between filtrate the world of
high fashion
meet the biggest supermom the whole
world right now is all are you like a
male model or female model all is all
he's asking do you have a hot dog or a
bun
there's only one criminal mastermind who
could be behind all this
Prison changed feat
bad to the core now
talked where's my goddamn latte who says
swimsuit models are useless take me from
behind and grab me like your life
depends on
not like this this for safety and
buoyancy wait what we are swimming back
to Rome oh ok divisor would trust me
leave them Spring Break huh hey heated
hitter here at pappas of them ethnicity
oops just the citizens need H me positas
mista